has it gotten easier for you from the
3rd to the 4th I mean in terms of
trusting in that process because I think
so many people have that mindset where
oh it's going to be this one and that's
all I'm going to need and then I can
just you know wave goodbye or some other
gesture to my old life um but has it
gotten easier or is it so scary because
now you know the realities of it you
know definitely gets a little easier
going from film to film but what gets
you know more worrisome in this in this
time is like the market changes like you
feel it happening like there was a time
early on when I was releasing films
digitally and getting great attention
for that as you've seen with YouTube and
and the amount of views that 10 miles
per hour god I mean it was the first
feature-length documentary on YouTube
and so when I took those risks like it
was awesome because people are like wow
check this out i got so much attention
nowadays it's harder to get that
attention because there's so many other
like films like and and and filmmakers
that are sort of like you know propping
up and trying different things and
getting sort of a little more riskier in
their approach its kind of but that's
fun too because it's like this anything
goes moment you know in in the film in
the film world but so I enjoy that I
embrace it but I do get to that point
where I don't know if what I did last
film was going to work again this film
you know even when it comes to like
raising money before film like I've
traditionally gone to sponsors and found
you know corporate sponsors or nonprofit
sponsors to come on board and get
excited about a film concept and help
essentially fund that film and that
takes the edge off of me quite a bit
because then I don't have to worry about
either dipping into my own own money or
using too much of my and you know sweat
time to like go out and totally shoot
shoot a film and make a film so those
old tricks they don't always stick
around you know in this day and age when
films changing so fast so you're
reinventing the wheel it sounds like
ever
every each time you go out and do that
you yeah you do have to reinvent the
wheel and something I'm realizing is you
each film that I make tends to go to
different sort of audience and I like
that I like that creative ability to to
change my my approach on these stories I
don't want to necessarily just make
cycling films I don't want to get
branded as that guy and so but I love
making those films that I've worked with
Mike on those before but when you you
make a new film like now we're made a
film about the world's oldest people and
it's like okay who are you going to
market this to you know some of the same
lessons and things we know from the past
don't necessarily apply to this new sort
of genre and this approach that that we
have to face so that's that's the tricky
part and while that's fun and
challenging it can be a little daunting
to
you